opposition leader Nelson Chamisa insists
he won Zimbabwe's presidential election
that's after the Zimbabwe electoral
commission declared President Ms
monangagwa had won a second and final
term in office jamisa citizens Coalition
for change party plans to challenge
those official results saying they
differ from their independentally he
wants African leaders to put pressure on
president Mr managawa to address
accusations of widespread vote rigging
and he accused him of wrongdoing
knows that he has performed a coup since
2008 echo on the ballot 2017 a coup
under elected leader 2018 ballot he has
repeated again 2023 a coup on the ballot
you can't survive this for far too many
times
denies allegations of Fraud and since
those who feel the race was not run
properly she go to court
we assuming our detectors
who wish to see us divided
forever to remain a United
peace loving and resilient people
okay
voting may be over but everyday
struggles remain for millions of
zimbabweans high inflation poverty and
unemployment
electoral disputes are also worrying
some people it's generally calm and
quiet across the country but dried
police and water cannon trucks had been
deployed to specific areas as a
precaution in case there are problems
the election five years ago was also
disputed the Constitutional Court upheld
manangago's election win zimbabweans and
the International Community are now
watching what happens this time around
Harare
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera